[Music]  well Ozzie Gian's in trouble y'all know  about this Miami Marlins manager ozzie  guillen is in trouble for some comments  he made about Fidel Castro yeah he said  that he loves Castro and respects him  for being able to stay in power for so  long as you can imagine his comments  upset a lot of people especially Cuban  Americans so today they were trying to  do some damage control  Ozzie held a press conference to  apologize I have to tell you I think he  made things a little worse take a look  yo creo que I am very sorry I do not  love Fidel Castro I hope that clears  everything up but as long as I'm here  let me just say that al Qaeda is doing  God's work Stalin gets a bad rap I am a  pony the fire-breathing opponent  and lastly Brett Ratner is quite simply  the greatest director in the history of  cinema  now he's in trouble  you